And now the old scout master.
So it's nighttime at summer camp and the scouts are sitting around a picnic table getting bitten by mosquitoes.
So they decide they're going to move and they go to another picnic table and soon there's some fireflies floating around
and one of the boys says: well, I give up, I'm going to bed.
Now the mosquitoes have flashlights and they're looking for them.
Hey, this is podcast number 75..
Hey, this is Clark Green. welcome back to the Scout Master podcast.
So let's see here. looking in the mail bag,
We heard this week from Blaze Vitale, who is a new scout master out in Wisconsin.
He says: overall I've really enjoyed the time with my troop.
I feel like stepping up to become a scout master has given me more of a sense of purpose to my life
and it's going to positively influence my family, particularly my son,
The boys in the troop and the community.
I've learned lots from your podcasts and several of the books you've recommended.
The last podcast about summer camp was excellent.
I wrote out a synopsis of that section of the podcast and emailed it to all the parents who were coming.
Your podcast consistently draws me back and continues to be my favorite.
I like the new website as well and the increased volume of post
which have been coming out over the past several months.
Great work. well, thanks, Blaze,
And I've been keeping up with Blaze over the past few months.
He's a new scout master, as his message implied there,
And it's just great to follow that.
Thomas Hulahan, assistant scout master with Troop 364 in Virginia Beach, Virginia,
was a winner of one of our latest caption contests
And he wrote to say this: first off,
let me compliment you on your podcast- simply outstanding.
The only shortcoming, in my opinion, is they're not long enough.
Well, thanks, Tom.
Your knowledge, insight and humor is greatly appreciated by all that listen to you.
I am sure
I was a highly decorated Weebelos leader.
Did you get the Weebelos purple heart and all that?
Yeah, me too.
And now I'm in my third year as an assistant scout master.
The group of boys who bridged over with me are still at it
And they're still with the program
And we've done a good job recruiting and we have about 60 scouts now
And we seem to continuously be growing.
Once again, thank you for your dedication to scouting.
Please keep up the good work.
Well, thank you, Tom.
It's good to hear that three years later, things are still moving along strong, 60 scouts.
That's a good size bunch
And I appreciate you listening,
I appreciate you being in touch.
I'll remind you, guys out there and girls, how to keep in touch.
You can email me at scoutmastercg at Verizonnet,
And you can check out the blog at scoutmastercgcom,
And well, we'll let you know how to follow us on Facebook and Twitter and all that stuff before we leave today.
Today, on the podcast in scout master ship, in seven minutes or less,
we're going to continue with our summer camp preparations
And this time around we're going to talk about how to prepare parents for summer camp,
Not the ones who'll be going down and accompanying the scouts to summer camp,
but the ones who'll be staying home.
Oh yeah, they need a little help too.
And then we'll move on to talking about the older boys in scouting
and exactly what we do and how we deal with that and the older boy question.
I'll warn you ahead of time, it's a little bit of a rant.
It's probably totally a rant.
So you know, if you want to skip that part of the podcast, feel free.
Hey, I think that's enough to do for a mid-summer podcast, don't you?
Well, let's get started, shall we?
Scout master ship in seven minutes or less.
So once we've got the scouts prepared to go to camp,
once we've prepared the troop, we've done our lists, we've sent our money,
we've done forms and we've scheduled adults to be at camp and all that kind of stuff
and figured out schedules of merit badges and all that business.
You know we're ready to go,
but what we're doing is we're leaving a group of parents behind at home
and a lot of times we haven't prepared them at all.
Now this is usually going to concern mothers
and it's usually going to concern families whose scouts are going away to camp
for their first year.
That's just my experience.
I know that dads have a lot of the same concerns,
but I usually tend to hear these concerns more from mothers
or just kind of sense that there's some tension
or some reluctance or some questions about going away to camp
that mothers have, especially that first year,
and we have not always done a very good job of preparing them for this.
Parents themselves are pretty concentrated on getting the boys ready for camp
and they might be unaware of how much they're going to miss
and worry about their scout while he's away.
or they may be aware of it and find it really kind of difficult to deal with.
They may feel uncomfortable turning over full-time care to people
they've just really gotten to know.
If we're talking about a boy going to summer camp for his first year,
he's been with a scout troop since maybe February
and has been on three, maybe four camp outs
and this may be enough to get to know the family pretty well
and know the boys pretty well and for the families to grow
and to trust the adult leadership of the troop.
but it's still a very big step
Sending your son away for an entire week
and it may be the first time he's been away for that long from home
and it's not necessarily people you know really, really well
and that you've known for years and years.
And parents worry about the kind of food that they'll be eating
and who'll be looking after, the daily concerns of clean clothes
and maybe taking a shower every once in a while.
They'll be worried if the other boys will tease their son
or if their son will be able to find his way around camp.
They worry about a lot of things
And what happens if he doesn't like being at camp?
Can he call home?
Can I call him?
How am I going to know what's going on?
It's an uncertain time.
I see this anxiety in the parents of scouts headed for camp
for the first year all the time.
Some of them find the experience a lot more difficult
than their sons ever will.
They don't find a whole lot of solace in the first letter
that they get from their scouts. either
Hey, I am having good time at camp, See you later.
Or hey, I hate camp, I'll see you later.
Or yeah, John broke his arm, See you later.
You know there's not a whole lot communicated there
and they're not going to necessarily get a letter back to him
in reply to that one within a week's time,
depending on where the camp is.
You understand what I'm saying.
You probably will remember this from the first year
that your son went away to camp.
But you know, if you're listening to this podcast,
it's pretty likely that you went with him.
But these are real things.
How can we, as scout leaders, help parents prepare
for how they're going to feel once they've dropped their sons off
and they return home? for you know
what could be a very quiet and a very long week.
Being separated from a child for this length of time
is a challenge for every parent,
even though many other parents have gone through it before.
So here's some thoughts that I think will help parents
be prepared for their sons going off to camp
for the first time,
And you know, the first one's pretty easy.
It's acknowledged that this causes, most parents
at least, some distress,
And it's really a normal part of a child growing up.
It's temporary, even though it might feel like
a week is a long time
and you're going to feel better.
Yeah, you will.
It's stressful.
It's stressful for a parent.
It can be very difficult.
It can be a great relief, you know,
for the scouts to go away for a week,
but they're still going to be worried
and they're still going to be a little stressed
Now. most scouts are going to encounter some homesickness
and some ups and downs.
We're going to talk about how to deal with homesickness
in our next podcast.
but you know we understand,
as experienced leaders,
that most scouts are going to encounter some homesickness
the first year that they go away
and sometimes the second and third year too,
And they're going to have some ups and downs.
They're going to enjoy some parts of camp
and not enjoy some others.
They're going to be some challenges.
What we can help parents understand
is that his fellow scouts and the adult leaders
that will be at camp with him
and the camp staff are all working hard
to make sure that it's overall a positive experience,
that it's a measured challenge
that scouts can overcome-
and they do that year after year after year.
We can let parents know that we expect some homesickness,
We expect it
And we expect other difficulties to arise
and we're prepared to deal with them,
And that they also
may be a little difficult,
they may be a little distasteful for a scout,
but they're a part of a healthy growing process
that all scouts are going to encounter in one way or another.
I don't like to make a big issue of it
because sometimes it can be a little distracting,
but you know, every one of our children
one of these days
is going to pack their things
and going to head out
and make their own way in the world.
And if they have
the experience of going away to summer camp
before they're going to pack their bags
and move out of the house
and end up at college
or end up going off on their own,
you know it's going to be a positive
experience for them and they're going to learn some things.
I know that when my son
went away to college
and he came home
for that first
break in the fall
he was absolutely stunned
at how naive
and unprepared most of his fellow
freshman students were
that he shared a dorm with
for the college experience.
And they were unprepared.
I mean, he was amazed that
very few of them knew how to do laundry
or knew how to look after themselves.
We're able to survive.
you know about very basic
day-to-day things.
He had
been, let's see,
to summer camp for
three or four years,
for a week at a time
as a boy
and then joined the camp staff- for
I guess he was there for about four years
full-time during the summers-
And so, going away to college
he was ready.
He knew how to look after himself.
He knew how to deal with any
feelings of homesickness
or anything like that. He knew how to make friends.
He knew how to work with groups of people.
So I try
and let parents know that this is a very positive
experience. even though there might be
some stress and some negatives involved with it,
it's overall a very
positive experience for a scout.
So we want to encourage parents to think
positively about the time that
the boys are going to be spending at camp. Scouts
typically thrive at summer camp
and return home very happy.
They may have had a rough time here and there, but
when it's all over they're happy
scouts.
I would say that in the run up to summer camp,
instead of
discussing and sharing your worries as a parent
with your scout
or how much you're going to miss him,
talk about all the great new experiences
that he's going to have
when he goes away to camp. Ask all
the questions of all the adult
leaders that you need to ask.
There are really no silly questions, No,
And
hopefully you don't get an attitude
from any adult,
because it's better to ask than to worry.
You know, if you need to ask about the food,
if you need to ask about the shower
facilities, if you need to ask about the campsite,
if you need to ask about
what they'll be doing,
definitely ask.
And then understand
as a parent and respect
the rules and times for
helping off and picking up
and visiting camp.
Some places in the country
camps pretty good distance
and parents aren't going to be visiting.
Some places have
a regular schedule
where there's a day, usually late in the week,
where parents come and visit and see what the boys
have been up to. But understand
and respect those rules.
I think that's really, really
important for parents to know,
Also understand and respect
how you'll be communicating
with your scout
and how he'll be communicating with home.
For the most part,
I like to see the communication
be
very limited
and I like to see it be
under the
oversight of the adult
leaders that are there at camp,
And that can be really rough for a parent,
and so understanding how
that's going to work up ahead of time
is going to be important for them,
And I would lay that out.
I would make sure, as a scout leader, that I've laid
that out very clearly.
I encourage parents to plan something
interesting or special to do while their
boys away at camp. You know, make some
plans for that week, Don't just sit around
and worry about the boy. Those are
just a few of the issues
that we are working with in preparing
parents for summer camp.
It's one of the things that often gets overlooked
in
the hundred of other details
that you're taking on.
And keep your eyes open, because anxious
parents are very easy to spot-
and make sure that you've answered
all the questions that they need to have answered
and that they're going to feel
as secure as possible
about sending their scout away to camp for the first
year And you know
it's almost always-
I would say 99.99%
of the time in my experience-
it's a positive
experience for the parents
and for the scout.
Music,
Music.
Hi, I'm Kevin Cowan and I'm listening
to scoutmaster ipod.
No, I can't.
Music,
Music.
I am Kevin Cowan, the happy camper,
and you're listening to the scoutmaster podcast.
Oh, beautiful,
Music,
Music.
That's right, it's time
for a scoutmaster's minute.
Music,
Music.
One of the fun things about having a blog is
you post something out there and then
a discussion begins
in the comments section of the post
and you get a lot of interesting ideas,
reflections and perspectives on things,
and one of the recent posts on the blog
was about whether or not
parents should push their
sons to stay in scouting,
and one of the ideas that came out of that
was talking about
the retention of older boys.
you know, boys who were 15,, 16, 17,
and
it was suggested
that
if scouting wants to keep boys that are that age,
they have to give them age-appropriate
programs, apart from the troop program,
and
that was the only way that we're going to keep them
as a part of scouts.
Here comes the rant
that I warned you about earlier.
but I just think that is just total malarkey.
I don't believe it at all.
I've heard about it for the past 25 years
and I got to tell you it's just not
been my experience.
we talk about it at the troop level.
you know, in training programs
and things like that,
there's this constant
at a 5
at a district to council level,
especially at our summer camp,
about the older boy programs
and we have to have these, otherwise
they're just going to walk away from scouting.
there's the talk about that
and the venture program and everything.
oh my gosh, we have to have
the whole scout program is geared for
the younger boys in the troop,
and the older boys they just lose interest
and they leave.
but this is actually what happens in our troop
boys. on average,
of that 35, I would say
about a half of them
are 15, 16, 17 years old.
so
somewhere between 10 and 15 of them,
let's say.
and of that 10 or 15
we lose about 4 of them,
3 to 4 of them
every year.
and the reason that we lose them
is because they turn 18
and they graduate from high school,
and that's why we lose them.
we don't lose them because they quit scouts.
we don't lose them because
they stop showing up
and they don't retrader.
we lose them because
they turn 18 and they're too old to be scouts
now.
in the interest of full disclosure
and complete honesty,
I think probably of that group of boys
who are 15,, 16,, 17 years old,
1 to 2
we might just lose over
the attrition of them finding
something else to do and not being interested
in scouts anymore.
now, that's not an older boy problem,
that's just
not an older boy problem.
I guess,
and I hear from people
who have a scout troop
who somehow
either perceive or actually lose
a lot of older boys over time.
and I have the antidote for it.
if you do have an older boy problem,
I hear an awful lot about them,
so there's got to be some out there.
I have a quick two step program
for you to eliminate your older boy
problem.
step number one:
use the patrol method and make sure
that scouts are leading their own troop.
I know everybody's tired of hearing about it,
I know,
but if you want to retain older scouts,
have them lead their own troop.
step number two:
let them set their own level of participation.
don't tell them
how much they have to participate.
okay,
for every highly engaged older scout
in a key leader position
in our troop,
I have one who is less active
and less engaged because
he's doing other stuff too.
he's playing football
or he's on some academic team
or he's following a very strong
academic course in school,
and
you know
he is less active
than his fellow scouts.
but I don't get angry with him
and I don't put policies in place
designed to make him feel bad
with certain percentages
of things that he must do
or something like that.
not every boy is going to step into
a senior leadership position.
some of them are going
to be involved to a certain point
and that's what they want to do
and that's it.
and if you're not prepared for that to happen,
you're going to have an older boy problem,
I can guarantee you
now.
as a result,
we retain a lot of those older boys.
they remain active
all the way until they graduate
from high school.
that's the way that it works.
now, one thing that we do have-
that is kind of a natural outgrowth
of the things
that scouts do-
is we do have one annual trip
that is a venture patrol trip
for boys
from 13
up,
and usually that's a canoe trip.
this year it happens to be a trip
to Kandersteg International Scout Center
in Switzerland,
but we do have that
and that I guess you could call
an older boy program.
but the real older boy program
is that they
lead their troop.
they lead it
every time you meet.
they lead it when we go to summer camp.
they lead it when we go camping.
they lead it at the venture patrol trips.
I mean, come on, folks,
that's what keeps them interested
and challenged and engaged.
there is
no older boy problem
when you run the patrol method
and scouts lead their own
troop.
so if you're having an attrition problem
with boys who are 15, 16
and 17 years old,
then you need to go back
and you need to look at the way your troop is being run,
because
my guess
the boys aren't running it,
and you need to look at
the way that you're making a guy feel
if he's truly interested in sports
or academics or something else
outside of scouts
and he feels as though he's penalized
for being interested in things outside of scouts
and doing other things in his community.
those are the two things that
may be causing an older boy
problem
and that's a pretty easy fix.
it's a pretty easy fix.
I'd love to hear your ideas and your experience
about this question,
and you're going to learn how to get in touch with me in just a moment.
Music.
Well, thank you for listening
and here's how to keep in touch
with our blog at
scoutmastercgcom.
scoutmaster
letter c, letter g-
com.
you can subscribe to the scoutmaster newsletter
when you go to the blog,
and that's a monthly digest of the scoutmaster blog
and the podcast with some great scouting resources
around a monthly theme,
and every newsletter includes a giveaway
from one of our affiliate sponsors.
this month
the theme is the patrol method
and we have several copies of that
to give away for
people who are randomly drawn
from all of those who
provide the correct answer to a scouting trivia question.
so go over to scoutmastercgcom
and you'll see how you can
subscribe to the scoutmaster newsletter.
Music:
you can subscribe to the scoutmaster podcast
on iTunes and when you do, feel free
to leave a comment or review or rating,
you can call and leave a voicemail message
at 484-734-0002
and you can leave a comment or a question
that could be featured in a
future edition of the scoutmaster podcast.
Music.
you can follow us at
scoutmaster blog on Facebook
and scoutmastercg on Twitter,
and you can email me
on the screen with all your comments and questions
at scoutmastercg,
scoutmastercg,
scoutmastercg.
that's the email address.
scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet
Music.
the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
hey, it's just me,
that's right. I have a microphone
and I'm trying to lend a hand to
scout leaders and perhaps have a little bit of fun
Music.
well, before we go, let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good camping.
well, thank you, sir,
until next time.
Music,
Music.